i know that republicans complain that
the schools were shut down during covid
and it is bad in terms of
children's
overall progression and it was
completely needless from the standpoint
of medicine and public health
but there are some benefits namely your
children were not
exposed for some period of time to
people like this
i love a bold eye and i love bold hair
and i love bold glasses and i love just
living loud and proud and out and like
to me this is this is my art this is
like my queer
art that i just exist colorfully every
day and
um i love a bold eye but here is one
place you should not wear a bold eye you
should not wear a bold eye
when you're going to hear mike curato
give a talk about this book because um
if you do
then there's a strong chance that you
might cry and have like a tammy faye
baker moment
yeah she goes on and on about this weird
like kind of porny book that she's
promoting she's a school library she's i
don't know what bold eye means
does that mean weird rainbow glasses
like the rainbow hair or like the
like the rainbow everything that's a
school librarian who is peddling
pornography to your children and the
argument that she makes not even so much
in that video but in some of the writing
that she's published is is really
profound she says that
queer aesthetic
is a form of resistance
so you hear she's talking about her
glasses and her hair and her look and
her this and this picture book and the
images not so much the arguments not
even the rights just the aesthetic is a
form of resistance and she's totally
right
and conservatives answer to this
shouldn't just be like oh whatever who
cares yeah you want to wear your crazy
hair you look like a crazy person that's
not a big deal it's really just the
rights and the arguments and the law i
don't know the conservative response to
that should be oh yeah you're right we
should ban that stuff
at least i'm not saying we pass a
federal law against stupid colored hair
i'm saying
that we need to have storms standards
and norms and in places like schools we
need dress codes we always had dress
codes in places for all of american
public life and then i don't know over
the last five minutes we've decided that
we have a first amendment right to wear
whatever we want in any place we want
that's not true when you go into certain
restaurants you need to wear a jacket
when you go to school especially for
most of americanist history you needed
to wear something akin to a uniform
and you couldn't wear dresses that were
too short and you couldn't wear you
couldn't have your hair in some crazy
way and you couldn't have piercings and
tattoos everywhere
there are rules
to how to dress and those can be
enforced by institutions and we should
discourage
the weird crazy
queer stuff
she's totally right
queer aesthetics is a form of resistance
and we should oppose that
it is ye
conservatives are really good at talking
about the truth we're really good at
saying no that's not true that's false
boom debunked owned facts and logic
we're really good at that
we're okay
at talking about the good
not all conservatives are not all
right-wingers some people don't want to
talk about the good they say well you do
you all do me we'll do whatever we want
that's true you're good might be my bad
whatever you know some nonsense but
generally conservatives have been
historically pretty good at saying no
there is such a thing as good and bad
and we should be moral and not be
vicious okay but conservatives are not
so great at talking about that third
transcendental of being
beauty
when we're talking about the
transcendentals we're talking about the
good
the true
and the beautiful that's what we're
supposed to pursue the good the true and
the beautiful
and the beautiful is really important
here too aesthetics is really important
here too
a man who is considered one of the
foundational conservative philosophers
edmund burke was an aesthetic
philosopher one of the most prominent
conservative philosophers until he died
a few years ago roger scrutin was in
many ways an aesthetic philosopher
beauty matters
okay the way we look
matters
because we're sensible beings right we
perceive things about the world and it
affects the way that we live
this is this is why
modern architecture is such a big
problem that's why right wing political
movements have taken an issue with
modern architecture and modern art going
back to max nordau writing the book to
generacion on on the
un unpleasant
turn toward ugliness in modern art
and that's a big problem for us
we need
conservatives have the confidence most
of the time some of the time at least to
say no that's not true that's false
you're not really a woman you're a man
and we're gonna insist on that we're
like pretty good at that and we're
okay
but not that not great
at saying no this is good and this is
bad and we should do the good thing not
the bad thing we need to get better at
that but we're just abysmal let's say no
this is beautiful that's ugly do the
beautiful thing donald trump it was my
favorite executive order he ever signed
it had no teeth it went nowhere biden
rescinded it immediately but it was the
make federal beauty make federal
buildings beautiful again act he said
look we have these beautiful old
buildings in washington dc then we have
this modern new trash that's so ugly and
it makes you ashamed to be in washington
dc let's get rid of that stuff and make
the new federal buildings neoclassical
and beautiful again
let's do that
and let's reinstitute some dress codes
it's going to be really hard there was
there was a case about this harris
funeral home case versus equal
employment opportunity commission went
up to the supreme court and it was about
a confused man who worked in a funeral
home who thought that he was a woman and
he insisted on wearing a dress and the
owner of the funeral home said look man
this is people are grieving they're
really fragile and vulnerable when they
come here and this is not the place for
you to make some
bizarre perverted political statement
about how you're really a woman that's
not what these people are here for it's
distracting it's real when you're
working at a funeral home it's about the
grieving families okay and stop making
it about you you can't wear the dress
put on pants like an adult like a man
and then when you go home if you want to
go we're dragged to some cd club at
night be my guest but not while you work
here and the confused man sued and he
won
unfortunately he won the case and so now
we're not allowed to enforce these
things it's very important for
conservatives to dig back in on this
issue and just stop seeding the ground
here you think it's a you think it's a
little thing
how we dress what we wear what we look
like but
it
it affects the whole it
truly affects the way we view the world
because it affects everything that we
see right now go to ahs.com
knowles we could all use some peace of
mind when it comes to staying on budget
right now that is why american home
shield exists as a member you know your
home budget and sanity are covered they
offer a choice of three great plans to
help cover the cost of repair or
replacing parts of major home systems
and appliances no matter their age if
american home shield cannot repair the
covered item they will replace it
american home shield members get more
more coverage options and fewer
exclusions from hvac systems and
plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
you get electronics coverage available
for an unlimited number of eligible
items such as smart watches flat screen
tvs and more
other options include roof leak repair
and pool and spa coverage coverage
available no matter how old your systems
and appliances are plus right now they
are offering an exclusive 50 bucks off
for our listeners keep your home up and
running and budget on track with
american home shield right now
take 50 off their most comprehensive
plans ever go to ahs.com knowles to save
50 bucks
ahs.com knowles for 50 bucks off any
plan american home shield be sure with
the shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply seat plan for details
i'm glad you like that clip now
hold on ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications that way we'll go from 1
million subscribers to 1 billion in no
time check it out we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]